my name is e today i'm going to talk
about improved hardness of bdd and svp
under gap seth
this is a joint work with hub.net and
chris picot
so the problems bdd and sap are known as
the lattice problems so i'll start with
introducing the notion of lattices
roughly speaking a lattice is a regular
grid of points in space
and more formally a lattice l of rank n
is a set of all integer linear
combinations of a basis b1 b2 till bn
here in the figure we could see an
example lattice generated by the blue
vectors b1 and b2 the lattice consists
of all the black dots that are the
integer combinations of the bases
and we could also observe that different
bases could actually generate the same
lattice
study of lattices is promoted by
lattice-based cryptography
nowadays we are approaching more and
more practical quantum computation and
it turns out that attacker with quantum
computation can actually break
cryptosystems that are based on number
theory one solution to this problem that
people find is to use lattice-based
cryptography since people believe that
some lattice problems are hard to
solve even with quantum computation
currently the state of the art attacks
to the united states cryptosystems are
based on solving exact or low
approximation factor lattice problems
such as the svp problem
based on this fact we also face another
problem that
whether the attacker can solve these
lattice problems in 2 to the n or 2 to
the n over 10 to the root and time has
actually a huge impact on the security
our work tried to address this problem
by showing fine-grained hardness results
for these lattice problems
the first lattice problem we consider is
the shortest vector problem svp
in svp
an important geometric property of
lattice is considered that is the
shortest lp norm of non-zero vector in
the lattice l denoted by lambda 1 of l
taking the previous example lattice we
could see that the
red vector b2 minus b1 is the shortest
non-zero vector in the example lattice
and its length or the radius of the red
circle is the quantity lambda 1 of this
lattice l
the gamma approximate svp problem in lp
norm
is the problem where we are given the
lattice l and the goal is to decide
whether lambda 1 of the lattice l is at
most one or at least gamma the
approximation vector
another lattice problem we consider in
our work is the bonded distance decoding
problem b d d
the b problem in lp norm with relative
distance alpha
is the problem where we are given a last
l and a target vector t
with promise that the distance from the
target vector t to the last l is at most
alpha times the lambda 1 of l
and the goal in this problem is to find
the closest lattice vector to t in
lattice l
note that here a smaller alpha factor
corresponds to a stronger promise that
the target is closer to the lattice and
this smaller alpha corresponds to an
easier problem
in the figure below you could see an
example of the bdd problem for euclidean
known p equals to 2 and alpha equals to
0.6
in this example if the target vector t
is within the green circles for example
if we take the red dots as target vector
t then goal is to find the closest
lattice vector to t
and if the target is outside all the
green circles
then the bdd problem does not care about
that case
previously we've seen that our goal is
to show fine-grain hardness of lattice
problems and a standard approach to
fine-grain harness is to assume
exponential time hypothesis eth
the hypothesis eth assumes that three
cents cannot be solved in two to the
little o of enzyme
a stronger variance of eth known as
strong egh or seth assumes that ksat
cannot be solved into the y minus
epsilon times 10 times
besides we also have the gap variance of
eth and scth where we consider the gap 3
set and gap k-set problems instead of
k-set and 3-cent
moreover we also have the randomized and
non-uniform variants of all the eth
variants above
where randomized or non-uniform time is
considered instead of deterministic time
for solving these problems
to remark as the name suggests
the strong eth is no weaker than eth and
gap eat gap eth and gap sagh is no
weaker than respectively egh and seth
moreover the randomized variants
are no weaker than flame variants and
the non-uniform variants are no weaker
than randomized variants
in our work we exploit the power of
these different eth variants and show
stronger harness results for the bdd or
sap problem under stronger variants of
eth
even if we do not care about lattice
problems this also shows that we have
interesting applications for all these
different variants of eth
more specifically to show the
fine-grained hardness of the lettuce
problems we reduce set on n variables to
the lattice problems in rank c times n
for some constant c
our first group of results are eth type
hardness results for bdd our first
result is that bdd cannot be solved in
two to the little o of n time for any
norm p and any alpha that is at least
some constant alpha k n which is
approximately 0.98
under non-uniform gap ath
our second result is similarly that bdd
cannot be solved into the little open
time for any non-p and any alpha that is
at least the quantity alpha double
dagger
while this time under randomized f eth
here the figure shows in comparison of
our result 1 and result 2 to the
previous bond
in the work dp20
the blue dashed curve shows the previous
bond in bp20 and we could see that our
result 2 always improves upon the
previous bond
and moreover our result one which is
which is the horizontal line
improves upon the result 2 for small
enough p
to remark in bb20 randomized eth instead
of randomized gap eth is assumed
so strictly speaking all the results are
not comparable
however we indeed shows that with
stronger assumptions we could show
stronger honest results for vtd
our results three is an s-e-t-h-type
hardness of b dt it says that bdd cannot
be solved in 2 to the n over c time for
any norm p that is not even integers
any c larger than 1 and any alpha larger
than alpha dagger
under non-uniform gap s-e-t-h
in the figure below we could see in
comparison of our results
to the previous bond in bp 20.
the blue dashed curve shows the result
in bb20 for c in the range 50 to 200.
the bond mvp 20 for this range looks
almost the same at the scale of this
plot
we can see that our result 3 improves
upon the previous bond for small enough
p and large enough c
also similarly in bp 20 it only assumes
randomized s-e-t-h instead of gap
s-e-t-h
our last result result 4 is an s-e-t-h
type harness of the problem svp it
states that scp cannot be solved into
the n over c time for some constant
gamma at least one
for any
norm p that is at least about 2.1
and not even integer nac at least
quantity cp
the result assumes randomized gap as eth
we remark that here quantity cp
approaches 1 as p goes to infinity
so that we essentially have 2 to the n
hardness for sap as p goes to infinity
here is a summary about the hardness of
the svp problem the previous work as18
has the similar results of 2d and over
cp hardness or svb problem but only for
the exact version of sv problem in
another world for gamma equals 1.
we improve this work by showing the same
2 to the n over cp hardness for gamma
equals 1 plus epsilon some small
constants
similarly in as18 it only assumes
randomized scghh while we assume
randomized gap as eth
moreover we have np hardness of the svp
problem for any constant
and when gamma is some large constant we
have two to the point eight and argosm
for gamma being some large enough
polynomial
we have a better exponential time
algorithm
and finally for gamma being some
exponential function
the scp problem is easy to solve by the
lll chromosome
in a proof of our results
a core technique we use is locally dense
gadgets output condensed gadgets
consists of a lattice l dagger in rank n
and a target vector t dagger
for the locally dense gadgets
we consider two point countings in
gadgets we denote by n short the number
of lattice vectors of length less than
one and by enclosed the number of
lattice vectors of distance at most
alpha close
to the target t dagger
we say that l dagger is locally dense at
t dagger if enclosed is at least new to
the n times n short that is if we have
exponentially more close than short
lattice vectors
here the important quality parameters of
locally dense gadget is alpha close and
new
in picture below we can see an example
of locally dense gadgets
here the rank and s2 and the lattice is
the 2d integer lattice
the target is all half vector
and we could see that by picking alpha
close to be one over root two
we have four closed vectors to the
target t dagger
while we only have one short vector that
is the origin
which has length less than one
so here
we have four times more close vectors
than short vectors
our main theorem for the ddd problem
tries to transform a locally dense
gadget to the hardness result for bdd
in particular
if there exists locally dense gadgets
lwt dagger with parameters alpha closed
and new
then for the bdd problem we show that it
cannot be solved in time to the little o
of n for any alpha that is at least
alpha close
under gap eth variance
here whether we have randomized or
non-uniform gap b th
depends on whether our gadget can be
constructed efficiently
moreover we show that bdd cannot be
solved into the n over c time for any
alpha that is at least alpha close plus
some excellent term
of due to dc minus 1
under gap s-e-t-h variant
here the epsilon term tends to 0
as new or c tends to infinity
recall that for smaller parameter alpha
the vdd problem is easier and thus the
harness will be the problem is stronger
so here
if we have smaller alpha close parameter
or larger new parameter
we get stronger hardness result for bdd
problem
this is intuitive since smaller alpha
closed parameter and larger new
parameter corresponds to a somehow
denser gadgets
a result by flooded shows that there
exists lattice l dagger with exponential
casing number
that is the number of lattice vectors of
length lambda 1 is at least 2 to the c k
n times n
where c k n is some explicit constant
that is about 0.02
there are pictures showing the casing
number for low dimensions
based on this result we construct
locally dense gadgets by picking
exponential case number ladders as the
lattice l dagger
and
set t dagger to be zero
by doing this it can be verified that we
get gadgets with parameter alpha clause
equals to 1 and nu equals to 2 to ckn
moreover we also use gadgets from the
integer lattices
by setting l dagger to be d to the n and
t dagger to be the all t vector
this is similar to what we've seen on
the previous slide
using these locally dense gadgets we
instantiate our main theorem and get our
results
we start with results three
the result three says that bdd cannot be
solved in two to the n over c time for
all alpha larger than alpha attacker
for results three we use the casein
number gadget recall that it has the
parameter alpha closed equals to 1 and
nu equals 2 to the c kn
by the main theorem we immediately get
alpha dagger to be 1 plus the epsilon
term
our result 1 also used the casey number
gadgets the result 1 says that vdd
cannot be solved into the little o of n
time for alpha that is at least alpha kn
in result 1 we try to decrease
alpha close for casey number gadgets
previously we set t dagger in the case
number gadget to be exactly the origin
zero
while here we try to perturb t dagger
away from zero while keeping the
parameter new to be at least one
eventually we get alpha clone
approaching the
quantity alpha kn which is defined to be
2d minus ckn
our result 2 use
gadgets from integer lattices instead of
casing number gadgets
result 2 says that bdd cannot be solved
into the little end time for alpha that
is at least alpha double dagger
in result two we try to minimize the
alpha close parameter in gadgets from
integer lattices
subtract to the constraint that mu needs
to be at least 1
and we get alpha double dagger as the
optimum
finally our result 4 is for the svp
problem it says sap cannot be solved
into the n over c
time for svp problem we have a similar
theorem
based on locally dense gadgets as we had
for bdd
and for result 4 we used the same
gadgets from integer lattices as in
result too
that's the end of my talk thanks for
watching